your Novell commnity LaDonna press
conference the visco person Tara or its
noble breeze ECC welcome to this press
conference where we will present this
year's Nobel Prize in Physics
we will keep to our tradition and start
in Swedish and then continue the
presentation in English of course you're
free to post questions in either
language later on hit estefan or Mac
os10 this secretary I have a humiliating
scoffs academia Oh me I'm a zombie
sister ahartry so cornica seekers from
snores caberta mere mortal pleased to
hear how a professor peddle Singh would
veranda in Nobel Committee infer
physique Oh telly monster professor and
Lily or professor Ananas sabor de la da
matta in Bell Committee on further
physique or its noble breeze harem use
comely appearance cops Academy in
habilitative telephotos Annabelle prissy
physique till professor isamu akasaki
the male University on Nagoya University
open professor Hiro Shimono
in Nagoya University open oak professor
Shuji Nakamura the University of
California Santa Barbara
you saw Academy's motivating leader for
opinion of Affectiva blue leaves the
order will come early you'd use dark oak
energy snowland Eva use Shalu
this year's price is about light the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has
decided to vote the 2014 Nobel Prize in
Physics to professor is amo
a Kazakh male University in Nagoya and
Nagoya University Japan
professor hero she Amano at Nagoya
University Japan and professor Judy
nakamura at University of California
Santa Barbara we saw
for the invention of efficient blue
light-emitting diodes which has enabled
bright and energy-saving white light
sources
professor Bedell Singh will now give us
a short summary in English please
so today the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences is awarding the Nobel Prize in
Physics for the invention of blue
light-emitting diodes red and green LEDs
have been around for many years but the
blue was really missing this lamp
contains three LEDs one red one green
and one blue if you combine these colors
you get white light this is something
that Isaac Newton showed already in 1671
thanks to the blue LED we can now get
white light sources which have very high
energy efficiency and very long lifetime
this LED technology is now replacing
older technologies in fact many of you
carry this technology in your pocket
their flashlights and also this screen
of modern smartphones uses LED
technology professor oiling and as will
now continue and give you some of the
details and we will continue to look at
the history of lighting which has been
around now for the last few million
years of human evolution we started out
by burning fuels inside lamps in the
geometry quite similar to that lamp we
see over there however that has mainly
be used here at KVA using incandescent
lighting an electric light over the last
hundred years or so since Edison
invented these things the fluorescent
lamp was introduced somewhere in the
early 20th century and then we saw much
much later the arrival of the lighting
element that we are now celebrating in
this year's Nobel Prize
what you see is of course an enormous
increase of the power efficiency of the
use of electrical energy in generating
light now something like 1/4 of our
electricity consumption in most
industrialized economies goes to
illumination so these effects having
much less much more light for much less
electricity is really going to have a
big impact on on our modern civilization
we see that impact you see it in the
streets you see it on the cars you see
it in the lights you see it in new
optical environments like this one from
a festival of lights somewhere in Japan
and they're all based on the use of
these light-emitting diodes they come in
different colors not only white but blue
red and green as we saw here and they
have not only the advantage of it but
much better using the electrical energy
they also give a very much longer life
time maybe a hundred times longer than
that of the standard incandescent lamp
that is now being going into retirement
also it doesn't bring the mercury long
that intermediate generation of
fluorescent tubes is contributing as a
problem to industrial civilization so we
will most certainly be able to use this
technology but it took a long while to
arrive at this possibility there are red
LEDs have been around since the early
1960s the green LEDs some years later
advances in semiconductor technology
using this bandgap semiconductors with
different bandgap slice at the highest
light lies at the base of this but the
blue thing the blue light-emitting diode
was very very difficult to accomplish
not that there was a lack of effort
there was continuous efforts in
industries to generate blue
light-emitting diodes because today we
did advantage of having these available
we can generate all those colors we can
combine in in color mixing with three
different colors in the individual lamp
or we can use as you find mostly may be
on the market today
or UV emitting LED illuminating a thin
layer absorbing this energy and
converting it to other colors the
structure of these lamps are very
similar to what you have at the base of
your semiconductor electronics that's
driving the information technology a
diode the combination of semiconductor
materials where you have one layer
carrying holes one layer carrying
electrons they transport these charges
at two different energy levels but when
they need in this intermediate layer the
active layer they recombine and when
they feel fall into each other they turn
up and turn light on that was light that
worries me there so this is the physical
mechanism that lies at the heart of this
device and our laureates of this year
have contributed greatly by the
inventions that made it possible to grow
the gallium nitride and alloys of
gallium nitride materials in the
particular geometry suitable for
building such diodes you have to be able
to grow these and that was attempted for
three decades before the in the
inventions of akasaki Amana and Nakamura
you have to be able to form these diodes
and there was a great problem with
passivation of the dopants being used to
create these it was solved by
discoveries and inventions in these
Japanese labs and you have to introduce
more colors and you have to build them
into structures which well confine the
electrons and the whole searching to
each other in order to generate light
emission and these are the structures
are as you find today a great number of
abbreviations on top of each other each
layer may be a fraction of a micrometer
thin deposited from the vapor phase in
big synthesis machines what you see in
the in the at the market might be a
light bulb like this whether a tiny tiny
speck of matter with this structure sub
my sub millimeter size is emitting quite
a bit of light
today or the yesterday when this figure
was compiled by satellite photographers
or NASA this is why we see light being
generated in the industrial economies
mainly and with the great urban areas of
the world but of course the access to
electricity is very weak in many areas
of the globe there is no electricity net
they don't have the electrical power
generation accessible this is changing
because solar lanterns being used too
little electricity help out in balancing
the systems where you have solar
photovoltaic plants and store them in
batteries for use at night so in the
future I believe this map will look
different and this is very much in the
in the mind of earth Nobel who wanted to
give his prize for the to the inventions
for the better been benefit on mankind
and this is why we award this year's
prize to akasaki Amano and Nakamura
Thank You professor
ingen s and we are now trying to see if
he can get professor and Nakamura on the
phone I should say it's about three
o'clock in the morning and I think I
woke professor Nakamura up just 15
minutes ago
so I said good morning professor
Nakamura are you there and
congratulations I'm sitting here in the
session hall at the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences and we have a press
conference with many interested
journalists from Swedish and
international press and all your ready
to take some questions from them
professor Nakamura yeah do we have any
questions for professor Nakamura good
morning professor congratulations
Tobi's Imus
we have already heard something said
about the significance of your
discoveries could you please tell us
what you think is significant it was
very difficult to hear your your your
voice is breaking up do we have some
other questions yes congratulations how
did you feel being woken up like this in
the middle of the night with a message
that you have won the Nobel Prize I
don't know if you heard the question was
just how did it what did it feel like to
be waking up in the middle of the night
with the message that you'd received a
Nobel Prize okay well thank you
professor Nakamura and and from all of
us here we congratulate you once again
and
and perhaps you can stop perhaps you can
go sleep a few hours but then I think
there will be a lot of media outside
your house so thanks again so order now
any questions - - to our experts here at
the pandal something that you would like
to to to have clarified
please
my name is efficient access zone from
freelance for channel radio I heard
these prices about the energy in hell DD
so when you consider this price is do
you consider the element that will be
contributed to the society in practice
more than the theory my response would
be saying that that we are cherishing
the tradition that Alfred Nobel who was
a great inventor he wanted his price to
be given to inventions for the benefits
of mankind and that's what we emphasize
today is the usefulness of this thing
and the usefulness in so many
applications we emphasize very strongly
the fact that it can be used for light
lighting but we've seen over the years
how these inventions of the blue
light-emitting diode was used in the
blue laser diodes used for optical
storage how coming generations of of
communication will rely on the use of
use of light rather than radio waves in
life I rather than Wi-Fi and how you can
use these blue or UV light in order to
sterilize water there are so many uses
of this and and uses I think is what
would make Alfred Nobel very happy maybe
less the discovery price has other price
but in invention price and in this type
of price we really emphasize the
usefulness of the of the invention and
this is the case in this case do we have
some more questions
if not a I like to - we have a question
over there
hello I'm Oliver G from the local
Sweden's news in English it was a little
hard to understand mr. Nakamura on the
phone perhaps you could recount how it
was to ring up and your probe from my
side we reached two of the three
laureates professor Amano happened to be
on a plane from Japan to France at this
very moment so we couldn't reach him but
we could reach professor Okazaki and and
professor Nakamura and of course they
are thrilled of getting this price and I
think actually they were not prepared
for it that they had not been waiting
all day and all night for this call and
if you happen to be on a plane I think
that's how it is and of course it's a
fantastic experience for us too to be
the first to to to wake them up or call
them in the evening and and congratulate
them achieving the Nobel Prize in
Physics so that's a great honor on our
part okay if there are no other
questions I'd like to to end this
conference and see you tomorrow when we
are announcing the chemistry prize at
the same time and in the same hole thank
you very much